ونحييكم مشاهدينا مستمرون معكم دائما في
هذه التغطيه على مدار الساعه للاحداث
الجاريه في السودان والاشتباكات بين الجيش
بقياده البرهان والدعم السريع بقياده
حمدوك هذه المعارك مستمره لليوم الثالث
على التوالي مع فشل جهود الوساطه المحليه
وايضا النداءات المطالبه بخفض التصعيد
ووقف لاطلاق النار
[موسيقى]
من
حوالينا
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا في اخر هذه التطورات تتواصل
الاشتباكات في محيط القيادات العامه للجيش
بالعاصمه الخرطوم ويقع مقر القياده العامه
في المنطقه الشماليه من العاصمه على بعد
نحو اربعه كيلومترات فقط من مطار الخرطوم
كما يتواجد بالقرب من مقر قياده القوات
البحريه ورئاسه اركان القوات الجويه ويعد
مقر القياده العامه مركزا مهما وحساسا
بالنسبه لقوات الجيش السوداني ويستمر
اطلاق الرصاص في محيط المبنى مع تداول
اخبار عن استخدام اسلحه ثقيله
اليوم محدوده جدا اقل عده بكثير من اليوم
الاول من الامس نحن نعصر عملياتنا في هذه
المرحله في التصدي لمحاولاتهم اقتهام بعض
المواقع مقرات القوات المسلحه في محيط
القياده العامه لجميع مق
رات
حتى مسيطره القياده العامه
وكان نفعل عميد نبيل عبد الله نطق باسم
الجيش السوداني للعربيه نفى ادعاءات قوه
الدعم السريع بالسيطره على اجزاء من مبنى
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه والقصر
الجمهوري وقصر الضيف
انه لا صح اطلاقا
باستيلاء او سيطره ميديا الدعم السريع
المتمرده على اي من مقرات القي اده ولا
على قصر الضيافه ولا على القطر الجمهوري
هذه التهذيب مضلله الامر الثاني نحن نؤكد
اننا المسلحه لاننا قوات محترفه وقوات
مسؤوله ونحن نلتزم تماما بجميع قواعد
الاشتباك في مثل هذه الحالات نحن نتقيد
تماما بمقررات القانون الدولي الانساني
قانون النزاعات المسلحه في هذا النزاع
المسلح
في المقابل مشاهدينا رد يوسف عزه المستشار
السياسي لقائد قوه الدعم السريع على
تصريحات الناطق باسم الجيش مؤكدا للعربيه
سيطره الدعم السريع على القصر الجمهوري
وعلى مقرات القياده العامه نستمع نحن
نسيطر على القصر الجمهوري نحن نسيطر على
كل المغاربه
المتواجده على طول شارع
نحن نسيطر على كافه مداخل ولايه الخرطوم
الكباري كافه الكباري
التي تربط بين الخرطوم والمدن الثلاثه
فقط عبر هذه القناه نطمن المواطنين ان
هنالك دعايه ان
الدعم المواطنين او ينهب ممتلكاتهم هذه
دعايه رخيصه نحن نؤمن المواطنين ويشهد
بذلك كل المواطنين في الشارع نوع من
المواطنين من المغاربه التي نستلمها ولا
ندخلها ولا نعتدي على وثائقها ولا على
اوراقها
[تصفيق]
هذا مشاهدينا ويضم الجيش السوداني عددا من
القاده البارزين برئاسه الفريق اول عبد
الفتاح البرهان كما تضم قوات الدعم السريع
التي يتراسها محمد حمدان دقلو ونائبه
وشقيقه عبد الرحيم حمدان دقلو ضباطا
ومستشارين نتعرف اكثر على كل هذا في هذا
التقرير
[موسيقى]
نستطلع الاوضاع الميدانيه مع زمينا من
الخرطوم وراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي سالم
اهلا بك معنا اسمح لي ان ابدا بما ورد من
تصريحات بخصوص السيطره على القصر الجمهوري
تبانت تصريحات من الذي سيطر هل الدعم
السريع ام الجيش السوداني هل لك بعد
تفاصيل التي يمكن ان تضعنا في اطار هذه
التطورات وتوضح اكثر الصوره
نعم اهلا بكم بكل ساده المشاهدين بدايه
ما يتعلق بالاحداث الجاريه في القصر
الجمهوري الاشتباكات وحتى التصريحات
والتصريحات المضاده لها
هناك قد انتشرت بين وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بان قوات الدعم السريع تسيطر
على القصر الجمهوري ثم جاء بعد ذلك نفي من
الجيش السوداني يقول ان القصر الجمهوري لم
تسيطر عليه القوات قوات الدعم السريع وان
هذه هذا البيان مليء بالاكاذيب هذا ما كان
الليل البارح لكن دعينا ايضا هنا نحن في
الميدان نستمع الى بين الفينه والاخرى الى
اصوات الرصاص وكذلك
المروحيات في بحري
وايضا راينا طيران حربي حقيقه لم نتبين
نوع هذا الطيران لكنه الطيران حرب ايضا في
السماء الخرطوم اليوم
نتحدث على طيران يحلق في سماء الخرطوم
طائرات استطلاع ام هناك عمليات قصف
لا طيران لعمليات قصف حقيقه لان هذا
الطيران كان يحلق لفترات طويله يعني او
على فترات طويله
نصف ساعه تقريبا نحن نستمع للمروحيات
واحيانا طائرات حربيه
وانواع اخرى لم اتحقق حقيقه من معرفه نوع
هذه الطائرات لكن ظلت تحلق قبل نصف ساعه
تقريبا من الان وهل هناك استخدام للمدفعيه
الثقيله كذلك كانت هناك بعض الانباء او
الاخبار مفادها بانه هناك في بعض المناطق
استخدام لاسلحه ثقيله وكان هناك حديث عن
مدفعيه ثقيله هل رصدت بعضا من هذه الاخبار
نعم هناك استخدام لانواع المدافع الثقيله
وكذلك مضادات الطائرات
والراجمات
والقذائف باشكالها ايضا كل هذه كانت كنا
نستمع اليها من اتجاه
كوبر والمنطقه كوبر وكذلك في منطقه كافوري
هنا في بحر وايضا هناك اشتباك بعيره ناريه
في تخوم الجسر الرابط بينهم درمان وبحري
وهو جسر شامبات ولم تنتظر به الرؤيه بعد
حتى الان
من خلال
من خلال مشاهداتك هل تغيرت الصوره بين
الامس واليوم بمعنى هل اتسعت رقعه
الاشتباكات هل زاد استخدام الاسلحه او
اننا امام هدوء حذر ربما يشمل بعض المناطق
هي اليوم افضل من امس بكل تاكيد يعني
كل تاكيد افضل من امس يوم هذا اليوم ربما
الاستخدام للاسلحه اخف او اقل كذلك
انواع الاشتباكات يعني تبدا ثم تختفي
وتبدا ثم تختفي لفترات احيانا اطول من
الفترات التي كانت بالامس لكن دعينا ايضا
هنا هذا يدفعنا الى الحديث عن
الوضع الانساني الذي تمر به البلاد الان
بدات في جوله لمستشفيات في بحري التي تعمل
وجدت من الذين وجدناهم في المستشفى ووجدنا
عديد من المرضى يتحدثون على انه هناك
مستشفيات عديده اغلقت ابوابها خاصه
مرضى غسيل الكلى الان يعانون معاناه شديده
في الوصول الى مكان فيه مركز غسيل كلها
يعمل وجدنا احد هؤلاء المرضى الان في
مستشفى البراحه ولكن لماذا اغ الابواب هذه
المستشفيات سالم فقط لنفهم هل تم
استهدافها هل صارت غير صالحه لاستقبال
المرضى مثلا
هم يتحدثون على ان هذا
الاغلال ان
المستشفيات الان تعاني من نقش الكوادر
الطبيه عدم قدره الفوائد الطبيه للوصول
للمستشفى الدعم اللوجي للمستشفيات انقطاع
المياه الان مستشفى البراحه نفسه والذي
كنا فيه والذي استقبل عدد من الاصابات
ربما تتجاوز العشر اصابات هذا المستشفى
الان يعاني العاملون في المستشفى وهذا ما
ذكره لي المدير الطبي تماما قال لي يعني
اذا لم نستطيع ان نوفر المياه الكافيه
للمستشفى سنضطر لاغلاق المستشفى لانه نحن
نعاني ولا قطره مياه واحده الان تنقل
المياه للمستشفى
بالسيارات
وبالبراميل يتم نقل هذه المياه لان
المستشفى يعاني ولديه عمليات الان الذكر
بان هذه الحالات التي جاءت اليهم في حالات
تحتاج الى عملياتهم حالات تحتاج الى بكر
بالنسبه للمصابين وهم اكثر من 10 افراد
وصلوا الى مستشفى البراحه
حالات حالات خطيره نتحدث عنها ولكن سالم
تحدثت عن مستشفى غسيل الكلى غير انك من
قبل ذلك اكدت على اننا نتحدث عن انقطاع
الخدمه في العديد من المستشفيات في الواقع
وليس فقط مستشفى غسيل كلا صحيح
صحيح هذا ما يؤكده
شهود العيان
المرضى الذين وجدتهم الان في المستشفى
اكدوا لي بانه مريض غسيل الكلى ذكرني باني
ذهبت الى ثلاثه مستشفيات من اجل غسيل
الكلى ولم استطع كلها مغلقه يقول مغلقه
مغلقه ووحده غسيل الكلى مغلقه في المستشفى
الفلاني وهكذا
هنا يعني الاغلاق هذا اسبابه كثيرا لكن
حتى اليوم استمعنا الى اغلاق مستشفى
الخرطوم التعليمي ابوابه مستشفى الشعب
اليوم ايضا
الاعتداء الذي كان على مستشفى ابن سينا كل
هذا يدفع الى انه يجب ان يريد الوضع
الانساني من كلا الطرفين لفتح ممرات امنه
وهذه هي النداءات التي
صحيح سالم طالما نتحدث عن الوضع الانساني
كانت هناك كذلك اخبار راجت منذ ساعات
مفادها بان
سيارات الاسعاف وطواقم الطبيه بدت غير
قادره على الوصول الى لبعض المناطق هل هذا
صحيح بمعنى انه حتى حصيله القتلى والجرحى
ليست نهائيه وهي في انتظار الوصول الى كل
الاحياء التي طالها القصف
هذا مؤكد تماما ان الاعداد الجرحى والقتل
لم تعرف بعد
الناظر الى هذين اليومين واليوم الثالث
النظر الى الكم الهائل من اطلاق الاعياره
الناريه واستخدام الاسلحه الثقيله بهذا
الشكل وبهذه الصوره وبهذه الفترات الطويله
وفي هذه المناطق الماهوله بالسكان
ويعرف ان لابد ان يكون هنالك اصابات
واصابات كثيره جدا هذا امر مؤكد والان حتى
موضوع عدم القدره على الحركه عدم القدره
على يعني تحرك الناس بشكل طبيعي في
الطرقات كذلك عدم فتح يعني
الاماكن الامنه او الممرات الامنه كل هذا
يدفع الى ان لا تكون الارقام دقيقه
الارقام الدقيقه تبدا بالظهور حينما يرجع
الوضع بشكل طبيعي ويبدا المواطنين في
الوصول الى كل المناطق بسهوله هنا يبدا كل
شخص بالتفقد وهنا ايضا منذ نريد ان نذكر
بانها تصلنا العديد من الرسائل والاتصالات
من ان هناك اشخاص مفقودين ايضا لم يعرف
بعد اين هم الان يعني وهذا هو المفقودون
الان يعني يملاون وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وكثير من السودانيين قد ابتدروا ايضا في
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي مبادرات للبحث عن
المفقودين كذلك وضحت الفكره سكتفي معك
بهذا القدر على ان اعود لك في سياق هذه
النشره او في نشرات قادمه شكرا جزيلا لك
من الخرطوم وراس العربيه سالم الهاشمي
نتابع دائما هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا من
الخرطومه دكتور رشيد ابراهيم رئيس قسم
العلوم السياسيه بمركز العلاقه الدوليه
والدبلوماسيه في الخرطوم اهلا بك معنا
دكتور رشيد الى هذه التغطيه المستمره
والمتواصله على قناه العربيه للتطورات في
السودان في الواقع هناك مناشدات لمحاوله
طرح حل لتهدئه على الاقل هل تعتقد بانه
هذا الحل وارد في الساعات القادمه ام ان
هناك حسابات اخرى للطرفين في هذه الساعات
على الاقل
نعم لعمله كل المتابعين والمراقبين والذين
يقيمون الاحداثيبعدون امكانيه الاستجابه
لايما دعوات
لوقف اطلاق النار وذلك من واقع ان الطبيعه
النزاع
الطبيعه سياسيه لا تقبل
يعني كرسي واحد لن يقبل غير شخص واحد اذا
اعتمدنا على انه صراع سياسي خاص بالسلطه
واذا ما اعتمدنا على المعيار العسكري
الجيش يعتبر ان هنالك قوه تمردت عليه
بقياده
حمايه وهي قوه خارقه وبالتالي لا يمكن
الحديث
محاورتها والا يكون انك اعتبرتها قوه
سياسيه ولكن الجيش يعتبرها قوه عسكريه
ايضا اذا اعتمدنا على معيار
المواجهات التي تمت
والدماء التي سالت قطعا كل هذه تجعلنا
استبعد امكانيه حدوث
تهدئه او حوار او وقفه الاغنر على الاقل
في
خلال هذا الاسبوع ربما قد تحدث متغيرات في
عالم السياسه كل شيء وارد ما لم تحدث
متغيرات كبيره تتعلق بالمعركه وربما نتيجه
المعركه
فلن يحدث هنالك استجابه خاصه انه الان
اوضعه السودان حتى لا تسمح باستقبال
مبعوثين يعني ايا كانوا غربيين او كانوا
من الاداره او من الامم المتحده
المطار لا يستقبل
صحيح ولكن كان هناك مبعوث من الاتحاد
الافريقي ثانيوي زياره السودان بالامس هو
كان هناك اخبار عن الاتحاد الافريقي
نفادها بان هناك مبعوث سيصل لاعب السودان
نعلم تطورات هذا الموضوع
في كل الحالات اسمح لي ان اعود لك بعد
لحظات الدكتور رشيد بعد الوقوف على هذا
الصور من الخرطوم نستمع لاصوات نار وكذلك
هناك دخان كثيف في سماء الخرطوم وكان
حدثنا مراسلنا منذ قليل على
اشتباكات متفرقه واستعمال اسلحه ثقيله هو
تحدث عن مروحيات تحدث عن طائرات كانت تحلق
في سماء الخرطوم سالناه ان كانت طائرات
استطلاع ام طائرات
تسيطر وكذلك هناك استهداف في بعض المناطق
واكد بان مراقبين
شاهدوا بان هذه الطائرات هي طائرات كانت
تستهدف بعض المناطق هناك حديث عن استخدام
اسلحه ثقيله وهذا ما اكده بعض المراقبون
في هذا الخصوص سنستمع لصوت الطبيعي نعود
من بعض لاستكمال هذه التغطيه
اذا مشاهدينا كنا في متابعه لهذه الصور هي
صور مباشره من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
كنا استمعنا لاطلاق نار وهناك اشتباكات
مختلفه في انحاء احياء الخرطوم تتزامن في
الواقع هذه الاشتباكات وهذا التصعيد مع
بعض التصريحات التي كنا نتابعها اسفل
الشاشه من الجيش السوداني الذي تحدث عن
انهاء الحاق وانتداب ضباط الجيش بدعم
السريع اعتبارا من اليوم كما تحدث كذلك
جيش السوداني وقال بانه يوافق على مهله
جديده لفتح مسارات امنه للحالات الانسانيه
لمده ثلاث ساعات كنا تحدثنا بالامس عن
موافقه الطرفين الدعم السريع وكذلك الجيش
السوداني على فتح مسارات امنه وممرات امنه
لمده اربعه ساعات ولكن تخللت الاربع ساعات
الشبكات واطلاق نار اليوم الجيش السوداني
يتحدث عن موافقه على مهله جديده لفتح
مسارات امنه للحالات الانسانيه لمده ثلاث
ساعات تطور ربما نسال فيه ضيفنا دكتور
راشد ابراهيم دكتور
تطور جديد ونقطه ايجابيه قد يعتبرها البعض
ولكن الى اي مدى يمكن ان تحترم هذه الخطوه
من كل الاطراف
نعم من الاحترام لابد ان يكون متبادل يعني
فلا يكفي ان يحترم طرف بينما يستغل طرف
اخر هذا الاحترام ووظيفه لمصلحه لمصلحته
وبالتالي احداث خسائر في الطرف الاخر وهذا
ايضا ربما يسال لنا نحتاج الى اليه مراقبه
ربما لقياس مدى احترام الاطراف يعني او
الطرفين للعمليه
دكتور حضرتك هذا صحيح ولكن حضرتك منذ قليل
قلت بانه
التطورات في السودان لا تسمح حتى بوصول
مبعوثين لا اقليميين ولا اممين من سيراقب
عمليه الالتزام بهذه الممرات
نعم هنالك البعثه الدوليه المتكامله لدعم
الانتقال السياسي في السودان هنالك اجسام
يعني
مؤسسات يعني على محيط
منظمتنا العربيه يمكن ان تساعد يعني وتقدم
بعض التجارب يعني في مثل هذه الحالات
وكذلك في نفس الاطار يعني يمكننا الحديث
عن
انفاز هذا الاتفاق هو
يعني وفق القوانين واللوائح التي تفرضها
قواعد الحروب وفضل النزاعات والقانون
الدولي الانساني الذي يحدد كيفيه استخدام
حتى القوه تجاه الطرف الاخر وينظم القوه
اتجاه الطرف الاخر بل لا يصيب الاعيان
ويحمي الاطفال ويحمي الزرع ويحمي الموارد
يعني هذه قيمه انسانيه وهي مساحه ايضا
الحرب ليست ليست بالضروره كلها قتل الاخر
وانتقام ولكن ايضا فيها نبل وفيها قيم
يعني كما هو في الادبيات العسكريه وفي
الادبيات القتاليه ولكن انا من حكم معرفتي
لطبيعه الخلاف وحجه يعني اتوقع من الصعوبه
بمكان الناعم ان نشهد التزاما يعني في هذه
على الاقل التزام من الطرفين من هذه
المهله لتمكين الطرفين صحيح لتمكينهم فتح
ممرات هناك خبر اخر كذلك اورده الجيش
السوداني يتعلق وسانقله لك وودات تعليقك
كذلك وتفسيرك لي هذا الخبر الجيش السوداني
يقول بانه انهى الحاقه وانتداب ضباط الجيش
بدعم السريع اعتبار من اليوم ما الذي يعني
ذلك
نعم يعني ذلك ان الجيش يدير العمليه ليس
بالسلاح وحده ولكن باجراءات الطبيعه
اداريه وضع الطبيعه مخابراتيه هو عندما
ينهي انتداب ضباطه في الدعم السريع انما
يحدث خللا في هيكله تلك القوات ويحدث
هيكله خللا في علاقتها ايضا سواء كانت
ماليه او كانت اداريه وبالتالي هو يربك
يربك هذه القوات ويضعف من قدره اذا ما
تبقى على السيطره والتحكم وبالتالي هو
يستفيد من هذا الوضع ويوظف ايضا كذلك عوده
افراده الذين كانوا منتدبون
عند الدعم السريع ايضا هو يستفيد منهم وهو
يدري
مناطق القوه ومناطق الضعف لدى قوات الدعم
السريع من واقع ان ضباطه هم كانوا الذين
يمسكون بمفاصل ويعرفون ادق التفاصيل يعني
ليس الغدرات وعدد المركبات ولكن حتى
صلاحيتها
وعدد وعددها والمسائل الفنيه التي تتعلق
بالمعادله التموينيه وبالزخاير بمواقعها
هذه معلومات استخباراتيه بالضروره هي
معلومه في مثل هذه الحالات يتم توظيف
المعلومات
لتحقيق اهداف واهداف عسكريه وربما اهداف
ذات طبيعه اقتصاديه في حاله الدعم السريع
فيما يتعلق بامواله واستثماراته ومناطق
تواجد يعني
ينتفع بها ربما كما قال مراقب في داخل
السوداني تفضل بالباقه معي دكتور رشيد
ساعود لك بعد قليل ولكن كانت هناك العديد
من ردود الفعل الدوليه في خصوص مناشده
الاطراف بتهدئه بخ صوص هذا الموضوع سنسال
زميلتنا راغده بهنام راغده اهلا بك معنا
ان كنت جاهزه طبعا معنا وتستمعين لي
المانيا كان لها تصريحات خاصه بمناشده
الاطراف للتهدئه دعينا في اطار هذه
التصريحات
اهلا بكريم بالفعل يعني سمعنا نداءات من
الخارجيه الالمانيه
باطراف الاطراف المتنازعه في السودان
للتهدئه ووقف القتال وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه انا قالت يوم امس بانه من
الضروري جدا ان نعود للعمليه السياسيه
وقالت مذكر بانه الشعب السوداني كان صوت
للعمليه الديمقراطيه
في السنوات الماضيه ومن المهم جدا ان تعود
السودان الى هذه العمليه والى النظام
المدني باسرع وقت ممكن تعلمين بانه
المانيا هي من اكبر المانحين يعني الانسان
في المساعدات الانسانيه للسودان وهي لم
توقف هذه المساعدات طوال العام الماضي وفي
الفتره الاخيره يعني رغم الانقلاب العسكري
الذي شهدته السودان وما حصل يعني في هذا
العام الماضي وهي قالت بانه هذه المساعدات
مستمره في محاذاه دعم عمل الامم المتح ده
ولكن راغده هل هل نفهم احياء العمليات
السياسيه ولكن هل نفهم من خلال هذه
التصريحات بان المساعدات قد تكون
ضغط مثلا او قد تستخدم برلين هذه
المساعدات للضغط على الاطراف لمحاوله
طرح هدنه معينه او على الاقل مرحله وقف
اقتتال مؤقت
حتى الان المانيا لم تتحدث عن هذه
المساعدات كل ما صدر رسميا عنها بانه يجب
ان يكون هناك تهدئه يجب ان يكون هناك وقف
للقتال وتاكيد على دعم المانيا لدور الامم
المتحده في السودان هي قالت بانه يجب ان
تقرا يجب ان ندعم عمل هذه يعني الامم
المتحده تعلمين ايضا بانه من المهم بانه
من يراسها هو دبلوماسي الماني وهذا يعني
بانه المانيا هي فعلا جزء من هذه العمليه
ولكن ليس كالمانيا ولكن
المتحده وضمن ايضا الاتحاد الاوروبي الذي
يعني سمعنا ايضا نداءات من
المفوض مفاوض الخارجيه في جزر كوريل
للاطراف بدات متكرره بالفعل منذ يعني بدا
هذه
الاشتباكات قبل ثلاثه ايام لوقف القتال
لذلك المانيا بالفعل هي لا تتحرك منفرده
تتحرك في اطار الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي اطار
دعم عمليه الامم المتحده التي يراسها
دبلوماسي الماني وهي يعني بالفعل هي معنيه
في هذه العمليه العمليات العمليات اعاده
الحكم المدني منذ سنوات منذ اصلا يعني
الانقلاب الاول او لطاحه بحكم عمر البشير
في العمل 2019 على كل ستبقين معنا في
نشراتنا القادمه
لمحاوله الوقوف كذلك على تطورات هذه
التصريحات الالمانيه شكرا جزيلا لك راقده
بهنا مراسله العربيه من برلين شكرا العقده
ونتابع هذه التغطيه باستطلاع الاوضاع
الانسانيه وهي من بين النقاط المهمه
والملفات الجد مهمه في هذه المرحله من
جنيف المدير الاقليمي للجنه دوليه للصليب
الاحمر في افريقيا باتريك يوسف سيد باتريك
اهلا بك معنا مبدئيا كيف تتابعون الوضع
الانساني الحالي في السودان غوتيريش كان
وصفه في مقابله بالخطير وصفه منذ قليل
بالكارثي كيف تتابعون التفاصيل
اولا شكرا لاستضافتكم اكيد الوضع صعب جدا
جدا واكيد ما فيهم من المبالغه وقتها نقول
انه الوضع ممكن يصير كارثه اكثر واكثر اذا
الوضع الانساني ما استتب واذا
المجال للمنظمات الانسانيه خاصه العامله
بمجال الاغاثه الصحه المياه انه
تتدخل بطريقه سريعه جدا راح نشهد اكيد
انقطاع مش بس بمواد طبيه ولكن عدم تسيير
المرافق العامه راح يكون للاسف الشيء اللي
راح نواجهه
قريبا وهذا الشيء ما انه ابدا ايجابي
بالعكس لازم نتدخل بسرعه لما تتفاقم
الاوضاع اكثر واكثر
بان هناك مستشفيات علقت عملها لانقطاع
المياه لعدم قدره الكوادر الطبيه للوصول
لها هل رصدتم او هل تاكدتم من هذا الموضوع
باتريك والله اكيد صعب كتير نتاكد من كل
المستشفيات المرافق العامه الكبيره اللي
عندها كميه وتستقبل اكيد بعدها عم تشتغل
بس مثل ما عم بنقول الوقت مش لمصلحتها مثل
ما بنعرف المشكله الاساسي اليوم اللي عم
نتعرض اللي عم تتعرض له العاصمه هو مع
استمرار الاشتباكات والاطلاق النار
والانفجارات عم تكون كلها على مقربه من
المناطق السكنيه المكتظه بالسكان وهذه
المرافق هل الاماكن لازم تكون عندها حمايه
خاصه للمدنيين بطريقه ثانيه بدنا نعرف انه
الاشخاص تعتمد وخاصه بالمدن الكبيره على
المرافق العامه لتوصل لتستلم خدماتها
الصحيه المياه الطاقه الى اخره وهذا الشيء
لازم نحميه كرماليك دعينا امبارح لضروره
احترام كافه الاطراف القانون دوله
الانساني والاعراف والقوانين السودانيه
لما تقول لازم نح بمعنى انه متابعه فقط او
انكم تتدخلون كذلك تطرحون افكار لمحاوله
فتح ممرات امنه لمحاوله التهدئه على الاقل
خدمه للمدنيين
التدخل مش بس باطلاق حملات
علنيه او اطلع بالاعلام الهدف هو انه نكمل
حوارنا المباشر مع الاطراف النزاع مثل ما
ذكرته كمان ذكرت العربيه اكثر من شهر كان
في ضروره تكثيف تدريب الكوادر العسكريه ان
كان الجيش ولا تدخل السريع على المفاهيم
القانون الدولي الانساني واكيد بمتابعتنا
الحثيثه على الارض مع الجهات المعنيه
العسكريه ونحاول انه نحمي هالمرافق بس
اكيد اللي حامل سلاح بده ياخذ امر لحتى لا
يؤذي المدنيين ولا يؤذي المرافق
قلت بانه منذ شهر تواصلتم مع الجانبين في
هذه الاسنان نزلتم تتواصلون معهم وفي اي
اط
التواصل ما توقف عم نحكي تاريخ صليب
الاحمر اكثر من اربعين سنه بالسودان ولكن
الهدف منه اليوم هو ظل ظروف الراهنه انه
التدخل السريع
لاستجابه للاحتياجات الانسانيه هو يكون
الاساس وبتامل اكيد نحن مثل ما بتعرفي
ستنا ما قلنا دخل بالعمل السياسي ولكن بهل
ظرف الخاص اللي عم نقطع فيه ضروري التذكير
ومتابعه حمايه هالمرافق العامه والمدنيين
والاشخاص المصابين يعني يضرروا الحمايه
معينه تحت القانون دوله انساني هو
ولكن ودت الوقوف معك على مجريات العمل كيف
تعملهم بمعنى
لديكم فرق على الارض
تتواصلون مع
الطرفين وما الذي قيل لكم هل هناك وعود
مثلا بمحاوله فتح ممرات امنه
بعد ما في وعود ولكن تواصل مستكمل اكيد
كان الصليب الاحمر اللي عنده اكثر من 400
موظف بدرفور بكثره بالنيل الازرق
وبالخرطوم
او الجمعيه الهلال الاحمر السوداني اللي
عندها اكبر عدد من
المتطوعين على الاراضي السودانيه او
المنظمتين والصليب الاحمر
بالاضافه الى الشهود الحديثه اللي عم تقوم
فيها منظمات تانيه وعم نتواصل معها هدفها
انه نوصل على ارض الواقع للاسف بعد
النتيجه الايجابيه ما سمعناها طيب منذ
قليل كان هناك تصحيح للسيد عبد الفتاح
البرهان الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان قال
فيه بان الجيش السوداني وافق على ثلاث
ساعات تهدئه لفتح ممرات امن الاكيد بانكم
استمعتم لهذه الاخبار والاكيد بانه هناك
عمل قائم لمحاوله ايصال المساعدات حدثني
كيف هي الصوره كيف تتابعون هذا العمل وكيف
تعملون من داخل السودان
يصير فيها اللي صار فيها بتامل انه الجهد
يتكثف اكثر واكثر خاصه اليوم انه الوضع ما
بيحمل ضروري انه نركز على الخرطوم ام
درمان مروي وغير مناطق عم يصير فيها
نزاعات واشتباكات عنيفه ولكن صليب الاحمر
لم يدخل بمساعدته للخرطوم منذ بدء
الاشتباكات او دخلتهم وفيما بعد ان حصلت
اشتباكات داخل ما دخلت من الخرطوم هل يمكن
ان تصل موجود هذا واضح ولكن بالنسبه صحيح
هذا واضح ولكن بالنسبه للمساعدات مع تعطل
خدمات المطار هل يمكن ان تصل مناطق اخرى
انتم حاضرون فيها ممكن اكيد ولكن بدنا
بدنا موافقه الاطراف وهذا اللي عم نحس عم
نشتغل عليه
تتواصلون معهم
ولديكم فرق على الارض صحيح اكيد
طيب بالنسبه للجرحى بالنسبه للقتله هل
تمكنتم من حصر الارقام لانه في الواقع
الاعلامي يتابع كما تعلم سيد باتريك لكن
الارقام غير دقيقه البعض يقول بان هناك
جرحه
لم تتمكن قوات الاسعاف او على الاقل فرق
الاسعاف للوصول لها لانه احياء
محاطه بالشبكات انتم لديكم تقارير حول هذا
الموضوع للاسف لا للاسف ما بدنا نقول كلام
يزيد من كميه الارقام المتضاربه اليوم
اللي عم نسمعها سمعنا ميه ميه وستين
بصراحه من الخطا انه اليوم قول اي رقم ما
يكون رسمي طالع من جهه رسميه وما بدنا
نزيد ابدا مثل ما قلت هالمعلومات الخاطئه
بنتامل انه بهالفتره الجايه نقدر الفرق
تقدر تنزل على ارض الواقع وتشوف بتتعامل
مع مكاتب الصحه مكاتب المياه يلي هي على
اساسها واكيد التواصل مع الجيش والفرق
العسكريه اللي هي اول واخيرا عندها بتكون
معلومات وهذا اللي بيقدر يعطينا لمحه عامه
عن الوضع اللي عم يصير اللي همي انا اقوله
اليوم هو انه مع احترام القانون ومع
سماح لطواقم الطبيه والاسعافيه والمنظمات
الانسانيه والعمل انا متاكد انه الوطن
بتكون اقل ولكن بدها قرار سياسي جريء
ليوقف اطلاق النار ليسمح
للمنظمات الانسانيه بالتدخل السريع ما
المنظمات ما المؤسسات التي تتفاعلون
تتعاونون معها في داخل السودان يعني اسماء
مثلا مع من تتواصلون الله اكبر هي الهلال
الاحمر السوداني ما عنا هو
الشريك الاول والاخير
الاساسي الموجود بالسودان وموجود بكافه
الاراضي واكيد في منظمات امميه مثل جمعيه
الصحه العالميه وغير مؤسسات عند عمل
مؤسسات سودانيه قبل ما تكون دوليه عم
تشتغل شغل ممتاز جدا ولازم دعمها واكيد
دعم فرقنا ودعم الهلال الاحمر هو ضروري
لانه اليوم مثل ما بنعرف الوضع الانساني
عامه حول العالم الاحتياجات عم تزيد ان
كان باثيوبيا ولا بالصومال ولا بغيرها ما
لازم ننسى اللي عم يصير بالسودان وما لازم
الاشتباكات بس تذكرنا بالاحتياجات
الانسانيه بالسودان السودان عم يقطع
بمرحله صعبه وضروره اليوم انو نامن
للمساعده ما هي مخاوفكم يعني انهي معك
بهذه النقطه منذ البدايه قلت بان الوضع
خطير وقادر ان يكون كارثه تتخوفون من ماذا
مع استمرار الاشتباكات والله متل ما عم
بحكي عم نسمع بالتقرير عندك انفجارات كل
حياه شخص سمينه جدا كل حياه طفل مراه او
رجال سمينه جدا كل حياه سوداني مهمه جدا
لالنا كرمالك لازم ننتبه انه ما حدا عم
يقول نحن اليوم ما قلنا دعوه
بالنتيجه اللي عم بيحصل سياسيا وعسكريا بس
منقوله هو انه ننتبه لحمايه المدنيين
ونامن الخدمات الاساسيه ما عم نطلب اكثر
من هيك للشعب السوداني اللي عم بيعيش كمان
مثل ما قلنا فتره رمضانيه حرجه جدا
بتاملها بوصول العيد قريبا انه تنتج لشيء
ايجابي او تشكرك جزيلا شكر على تلبيه
الدعوه وكل ما تفضلت به من معلومات من
جونيف المدير الاقليمي للجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر في افريقيا باتريكا يوسف
شكرا لك
نتابع مشاهدينا مع بعض الاخبار ذات الصله
حيث اصدر رئيس مجلس السياده قائد الجيش
عبد الفتاح البرهان اصدر قرارا بحل الدعم
السريع واعلاني قوه او اعلانه قوه متمرده
على الدوله وذلك بحسب بيان وزاره الخارجيه
السودانيه كما اكدت الخارجيه ان كل
الوساطات الوطنيه لدمج الدعم السريع
بالجيش قد بات بالفشل جاء في البيان ايضا
ان الجيش يعتمد استراتيجيه قتاليه لتقليل
الخسائر
وقبل ذلك كان نفى مصدره في الجيش السوداني
للعربيه ما تم نشره من قبل قوات الدعم
السريع حول اقتحام مقر اقامه البرهان واكد
المصدر للعربيه ان للشبكات جرت حول مقري
البرهان وحميدتي وتم ابعاده هذه القوات
وان فيديو اقتحام الدعم السريع لمقر
البرهان موضه للغير حقيقي
نناقش او نتابع رصد المواقف دوليه مع
زميلنا من نيويورك طلال الحاج مدير مكتب
العربيه في نيويورك طلال اهلا بك معنا
نبدا بالموقف الامريكي كيف هو وكيف
المتابعه حتى الان
جميع المواقف داخل المجلس الامن سواء كان
الامريكي او سواء كان للدول الاخرى وخاصه
البريطانيا تعرفين ان بريطانيا هي حامله
القلم في ملف السودان داخل مجلس الامن
وطالبت البارحه وبالفعل تم لها ما طلب
بعقد جلسه مغلقه حول السودان
بحاطه من
الممثل الخاص الامين العام رئيس
بعثه في السودان
في هذه الجلسه
الجلسه لم تتم بعد سوف هناك جلسه مغلقه
الان حول اليمن وبعد ذلك سوف تكون هناك
جلسه مغلقه ايضا حول السودان يناقش فيها
الاعضاء
حول ما يدور في السودان وحول وجهه نظر
الامم المتحده مما يدور في السودان وسيقوم
[موسيقى]
عقدي مؤتمر الصحفي بعد ذلك في غرفه
المؤتمرات الصحفيه الساعه السابعه عشر
والنصف بتوقيت جرينتش اليوم
لشرح الوجهه النظر الامميه وكيفيه
انهاء العنف بصوت فوريه في في السودان
الذين العام اغتنم فرصه وجوده في مجلس
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي اليوم في جلسه حول
التمويل لا علاقه لها بالسودان ولكنه طلب
الكلمه حول السودان
وطالب
بداها بالقول انه يجب قوه القتال الدائر
في السودان وناشد الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع بوقف العمليات العدائيه على
الفور واستعاده الهدوء وبدء الحوار حول
الازمه
الوضع كما قال ادى حتى الان الى فقدان
عدد كبير وفظيع من الارواح من بينهم مع
اعداد كبيره من مدنيين وان اي تصعيد اخر
سيؤدي الى تدمير البلاد والمنطقه حسب
جميع من لديه النفود جميع من لديهم نفوت
على الوضع ان يستخدموا نفوذهم من اجل
السلام ودعم الجهود المبذوله لانهاء العنف
والعوده الى المسار
الانتقالي في البلاد وسط بان الوضع كان
هشا في السودان والان اصبح كارثيا الامر
وشجب كل العمليات القتلي والجرح في
السودان الامم المتحده مهتمه جدا بهذه
الازمه تعتبرها في واقع الامر خطيره ليست
فقط على السودان بل علي المنطقه باكملها
واعتقد ان المشاورات دائره ليست فقط في
داخل المجلس الامبل في الاروقه وبين
البعثات الدبلوماسيه حول كيفيه التعامل مع
هذه الازمه
اهم شيء هذا هو السؤال صحيح ولكن تقول بان
الامم المتحده مهتمه وهناك محاوله للدفع
بمحاوله ايجاد حل ولكن بحسب خبرتك طلال في
متابعه هذه المنشدات وكذلك هذه الجلسات هل
ينتظر ان يكون هناك شيء معين
تقترحه الامم المتحده لمحاوله طرح تهدئه
في هذه المرحله على الاقل
لو كان لديهم اي شيء في واقع الامر معين
لطرحوه هذا الامر بدا من يوم السبت
والامين العام وبقيه الاعضاء والسفراء
يتابعونه عن كثب ودقيقه بدقيقه وساعه
بساعه ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه لا يوجد لدى
مجلس الامن خيار غير خيار المناشده
والمطالبه
وربما فرض الضغوط
والمناشده الانسانيه وانقاذ الارواح
وتوصيل مساعدات كل ذلك هو ما لديهم لا
يمكن للام متحده تدخل بصوره اخرى ان كان
ان كان البعض يعتقد ان هناك ربما تدخل
عسكري لا يمكن لذلك الا السودانيين هم
القادرون على حل مشكلتهم بانفسهم
وتغليف العقل على هذا الوضع الذي لن يؤدي
الا لا دمار السودان ودمار
المنطقه كما قال الامين العام بنفسه هذه
الازمه سيكون لها اثار
كبيره وسيئه جدا على السودان وعلى المنطقه
واعتقد ان الامم متحده تحاول
مناشدتها هؤلاء من لديهم نفوذ داخل
السودان ان يمارسون نفوذهم
لدعم الجهود المبذوله من قبل الجميع
للتوصل الى حل لهذه الازمه
الخطيره صحيح الخطيره والتي قد تنهك
السودان اكثر مما هو منهك في هذه المرحله
اود شكرا جزيل الشكر طلال الحاج مدير مكتب
العربيه في نيويورك كنت معنا منيويورك
ومشاهدينا القتال بين القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع ما زالت
مستمره وسرعان ما تداولت صحف العربيه
والغربيه كذلك اخبار الازمه السودانيه
الراهنه لناخذ جوله على ابرز عناوين الصحف
الغربيه
يا سلام
صحيفه وولشي جان الامريكيه عنون صراع مميت
على السلطه بين اكبر جنرالين في السودان
الصحيفه تقول ان الفشل في انهاء القتال
بسرعه ومعاوده المحادثات مع القاده
المدنيين قد يدفع السودان مره اخرى
للانزلاق الى حرب اهليه وفق محللين اما
صحيفه التلغراف البريطانيه فعننت حرب
بوتين انفجرت في السودان السودان يتصدع
تحت تاثير المرتزق الروس وقد يتم ربط قوات
الدعم السريع بمجموعه التي قيل انها ساعدت
في تدريبهم وتجهيزهم قد تواجه تشاد
واريتريا وجنوب السودان طوفانا من
اللاجئين ما يزيد من صراعاتهم الداخليه
الى صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه تحت
عنوان السودان يخشى من حرب اهليه بعد
انفجارات تهز العاصمه القتال في دارفور
عنصر قابل للاشتعال والصراع تعد دارفور
موطنا للعديد من الجماعات المتمرده التي
قد تنخرط في القتال صحيفه لوفيغرو
الفرنسيه عنونه التنفس بين العسكريين يجعل
الخرطوم تغرق في الفوضى على الرغم من
الدعوات العديده للهدوء من المجتمع الدولي
والقوى السياسيه السودانيه لا يبدو ان ايا
من الطرفين مستعد للتفاوض مصدر دبلوماسي
غربي في الخرطوم صرح للصحيفه بوجود عده
محاولات اقليميه ودوليه للمصالحه لكن
الامر معقد فالطرفان منخرطان في اسلوب
اللفظي وعسكري واحد
نعم العنوان الصحيح في كل هذه الصحف سواء
كان امريكيه او كانت فرنسيه او كانت
بريطانيه هو انها تعمل للحفاظ على مصالحها
بالدرجه الاولى هذا هكذا يقول منطقه
الاشياء
فرنسا متضرره جدا من توقل لقوات الدعم
السريع في تشاء وفي افريقيا الوسطى
بالتنسيق مع روسيا العدو في شرق
اوروبا يعني الذي يهدد الامن الفرنسي
والامن الاوروبي يعني في شرق اوروبا ايضا
يهددها يعني في مستعمراتها الفرانكفونيه
هذه هي المعادله الصحيحه ليست القضيه يعني
كما هو واضح يعني
بانها تهدئه لصالح السوداني كذلك ايضا
بالنسبه
لكل مصلحته ولكن هذا ما فهمته من كلام
حضرتك ولكن
افهم كذلك بانه اداخل السوداني لم يعد يثق
في المبادرات الدوليه لمحاوله احلال
السلام وبان السلام والاستقرار لن ياتي
الا من توافق داخلي في السودان
نعم لان العمليه السياسيه التي انتجت قضيه
الدعم وسارت الخلاف واوصلت الامور الى هذه
المرحله هي كلها
يعني قضيه خارجيه
ومبادرات خارجيه
ووساطات خارجيه الخارج بزخم الذي دخل فيه
من وساطات ومن مبادرات ومن اداره لمنهج
الازمه والذي اوصل الاوضاع الى ما هي عليه
انا الاوان لتفكير جديد نغير في وسائل
التفكير في طرائق العمل عسى ان نحقق نتائج
ربما تختلف عما وصلنا اليه الان وانا اقرا
ذلك من خلال تصريح الفريق اول البرهان بان
بان ما يحدث في السودان هو قضيه داخليه
وصراع داخلي وعلى الذين يحبون للسودان
الخير ان ينصحوا القوات الدعم السلع هذا
هو التحول الذي اقصده هو الذي عبره وخلاله
اقرا هذه التحركات دكتور رشيد اين هو
المكون المدني من كل هذا بمعنى هل تبعت
بيانات لي مثلا الحريه وتغيير بشقيه
هي السياسه الدوليه يعني علمتنا منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه والاوضاع الامنيه التي
نظمت العالم حتى اليوم هي مبنيه على
التقسيم كلهم مبني على انتصار
المنتصر يعني هو حقه في النقد الفيديو
يعني هذه مسائل بداهه معروفه ويبررها
قانون القوه في العلاقات ليس بين الداخل
فحسب وليس بل حتى مع العلاقات الخارجيه
تلعب القوى يعني دورا اساسيا في التنظيم
العلاقات وفي المقالب وفي كيفيه
يعني تمكين واحراز تقدم في صراع
دكتور بان وضحت الفكره حضرتك تعتبر بان
الجيش السوداني هو المنتصر حتى هذه اللحظه
مراقبون سيقولون لك ملاحظون بان دعم سريع
كذلك مستبسل هو مسيطر على بعض النقاط وهو
تمكن من السيطره على نقاط اخرى
وبالتالي بما يمكن تفسير
استمرار الدعم السريع واستبساله في الدفاع
امام جيش نظامي يعني منذ سنوات يعمل على
التسليح يعمل على مثل هكذا النزاعات ما
تفسير ذلك
نعم المعركه قطعا هي محسومه يعني كما ذكرت
لعل الكل
بمعايير القوه وتوازنات القوه بالعراقه
بالتاريخ بالتنظيم حتى اقول شيئا يعني قد
لا يتفق معي فيه بعض الاشياء حتى بالنسبه
للمجتمع الدولي امريكا مع مصلحه امريكا
يعني في ان يكون حمايه يعني قائدا وقوه
يعمل لها الف حساب يعني مع فاغنر ومع
روسيا وقضيه الذهب التي هي تعتبر معادله
مهمه جدا في الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
يعني حتى هذه يمكن ان يكون حولها تفاهم
ولذلك انا مرات تتفاعل يعني احس بان
امريكا تصريحات بلينكن تجاه الازمه في
السودان فحس بان هنالك تماهي مع موقف
الجيش وتفهما خاصه عند الفغر التي يعني
الان امريكا لا تصف ما حدث في السودان
بانه انقلاب لان تعريف الانقلاب عندهم
انه تحرك بالقوه من قبل الجيش لا تضحكونه
منتخبة وهنا في السودان لا توجد حكومه
منتخبه هذه حاله كما ان تصريحات باللي
يمكن ايضا الاخيره تنظر الى ما يحدث في
السودان بانه شان داخلي هذا ربما ياتي
اشارات مبطنه الان لا نسمع تصريحا لفولكر
وهو المعني او ممثل الامين العام والمعني
بالانتقال السياسي في السودان وصرح بانه
لا يمكن الحديث عن جيشين في دوله واحده لا
يمكن الاستقرار عن ذلك كل هذه غرائم ربما
تعطينا اشارات بانك بان هنالك مستويات
ربما من التفاهم ومصلحه امريكا ومصلحه
الغرب في المنطقه بان يكون هنالك جيش
سوداني واحد فضحت الفكره على كل سيبقى
موضوعا للمتابعه
على مرافقتنا طيله هذه الساعه من تغطيه
العربيه من الخرطوم الدكتور راشد ابراهيم
رئيس قسم العلوم السياسيه بمركز العلاقات
الدولي ه والدبلوماسيه في الخرطوم شكرا لك
مشاهدينا خريطه المعارك على الارض تنتشر
في العديد من النقاط الساخنه سواء في
العاصمه الخرطوم او خارجها وتدور اكثر
المعارك شراسه في مناطق متعدده من العاصمه
الخرطوم ابرزها مقر القياده العامه للجيش
الواقع في شمال العاصمه فالاقتتال مستمر
في محيط مقر القياده وسط انباء متضاربه
حول الجهه المسيطره على المبنى مبنى اخر
في العاصمه الخرطوم كان مسرحا للاقتتال
بين طرفين وهو مبنى القصر الجمهوري الذي
يتواجد في المنطقه الشماليه في العاصمه
وكانت قوه الدعم اعلنت سيطرتها قبل ان
ينفي ذلك الجيش لاحقا وفيمدرمان دارت
الشبكات في محيطه مبنات تلفزيون بعد
محاوله قوات الدعم السريع السيطره عليه
وفقا للجيش الذي اعلن سيطرته على المبنى
بشكل كامل وبعيدا عن العاصمه الخرطوم وهذه
المره شمال البلاد وتحديدا في مدينه مرويه
التي شهدت اندلاع شراره الاولى للازمه
فان مصير مطار مروي الذي يقع في الجزء
الشرقي من المدينه لا يزال معلقا في ظل
اعلان كل طرف بسطه سيطرته عليه
شكلت الازمه الراهنه في السودان ضربه
جديده للاقتصاد في البلاد واستمرار الصراع
العسكري قد يجعل من الصعب خروج السودان من
الازمه الاقتصاديه الضاربه بجذورها لعقود
مضت نتابع
لا يمكن رسم صوره متفائله للاقتصاد
السوداني في ظل التصعيد المسلح بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع قبل هذه
الاشتباكات كان الاقتصاد يرزح تحت سلسله
من الازمات التي يعود تاريخها الى حقبه
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير واستمرت حتى بعد
سقوطه في 2019
الحكومه الانتقاليه التي تولت السلطه بعد
اسقاط البشير احيت امال السودانيين في
تحسن احوالهم اذ رفعت واشنطن بلادهم من
قائمه الدول الراعيه للارهاب وعادت
مساعدات الاجنبيه التي ناهزت ملياري دولار
سنويا الا ان الدول المانحه قررت تعليق
مساعداتها للسودان بعد الاجراءات التي
اتخذها قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان في
اكتوبر 2021
وشملت حل مجلس الوزراء والسياده
الانتقاليين مؤكده انها لن تستانف دعمها
للخرطوم ما لم تعد السلطه الى ايدي
المدنيين
الاقتصاد السوداني لم يشهد نموا منذ عام
2019 الا في عام 2021 فقد سجل نموا طفيفا
بنحو 0.5% لينكمش مجددا في عام 2022 صندوق
النقد توقع نمو اقتصاد السودان خلال العام
الجاري ب 2.5 الا ان الاحداث الاخيره قد
تعيد الاقتصاد الى مربع الانكماش ويحاصر
التضخم الاقتصاد منذ اكثر من ثلاث سنوات
فخلال 2022 ارتفع التضخم الى اكثر من 154
في المئه وفي يناير الماضي بلغت تضخم
السنوي نحو 83% لكن هذه الارقام كانت قبل
الازمه الراهنه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع ويعتمد السودان على الخارج لتغطيه
معظم احتياجاته من النفط والغذاء وفي ظل
تدهور قيمه عملته وارتفاع الاسعار عالميا
سجل السودان خلال 2022 اعلى عجل في ميزانه
التجاري منذ 2012 ويساوي الدولار الواحد
حاليا في المتوسط نحو 600 جنيه سوداني
مقابل متوسط بين 18 الى 47 جنيها للدولار
الواحد في 2018 كل هذه العوامل انعكست
تدهورا في مستويات المعيشه وسط تراجع
القدره الشرائيه وارتفاع التضخم وارتفاع
مستويات الديون الخارجيه وغياب
الاستثمارات الاجنبيه وبالطبع وفي حال
تفاقم الازمه الراهنه فان كافه المؤشرات
الاقتصاديه ستسير نحو الاسوا محمد زهير
العربيه
مشاهدينا بهذا التقرير نصل الى نهايه هذه
الساعه ولكن تغطيه العربيه دائما مستمره
بعد قليل اكثر تفاصيل واكثر ضيوف مع زميله
نيال الاختيار اليك ليال
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات